das hofer bei kommt wie schwärme von
mini satelliten die die erde überwachen
und wie der ebola virus sich über den
flugverkehr verbreiten könnte das sind
drei der themen jetzt in den topf
news.de zum science fiction
mini-satelliten sammeln daten schwärme
von mini satelliten sind die zukunft der
datensuche im weltall das meinen die
forscher der tu berlin
sie haben einen satelliten entwickelt
der in einer handtasche passt und dem
weltall daten für die wissenschaft
sammeln soll
ganz allein schaffte das allerdings
nicht um fortlaufend daten
beispielsweise über das wetter zusammen
sind viele dieser kleinen satelliten
notwendig diese vernetzten schwärme
können vermutlich länger in der
erdumlaufbahn kreisen als andere
satelliten und mit hilfe der
robotertechnik lassen sich defekte teile
leichter ersetzen und lassen so eine
längere laufzeit zu daran arbeiten die
forscher
der vorteil der mini würfel sei dass sie
sowohl günstiger in der produktion sind
und auch kostengünstiger ins all
gebracht werden können meint klaus brice
fachgebietsleiter für raumfahrttechnik
an der tu berlin
so könnten auch große mit sendern
ausgestattete containerschiffe überwacht
werden und illegale verunreinigung in
mehr aufgespürt werden
die daten können von den
wissenschaftlern und ruth 150 studenten
übrigens nur abgegriffen werden wenn die
satelliten berlin überfliegen dort
übermitteln sie die daten an die tu
berlin
um die daten abzugreifen bleibt den
verantwortlichen immer nur ein
zeitfenster von sechs bis acht minuten
das hofer bei kommt ein traum für alle
science-fiction-fans das auf arbeit wird
entwickelt zwar ist der engländer chris
malloy nicht der einzige mit der idee
dennoch scheint er einen recht
vielversprechenden prototypen gebaut zu
haben bis zum ersten september lief
seine sammelaktion auf der crowdfunding
plattform kickstarter und dabei kamen
65.000 pfund zusammen eine lief termin
gibt es allerdings noch nicht
die firma iks eine weitere entwickler
gruppe plant mit einer vermarktung ab
dem jahr 2017
allerdings gibt es genauere daten zum
endprodukt von chris möller
es soll
3000 meter hoch fliegen und 45 minuten
am stück fliegen können zur sicherheit
wird den piloten allerdings empfohlen
einen fallschirm zu tragen das bisherige
modell ist 111 5 meter lang und wie 22
kilogramm
dazu kommt noch eine batterie mit einem
kilogramm die maximale nutzlast im
moment 47 kilogramm also ist noch nicht
so ganz für menschen geeignet und setzt
ich bin einen hauch zu schwer
ja das hofer bike ist quasi ein
schwebendes motorrad ohne räder mit nach
unten gerichteten propellern sowie bei
den drohnen die man heute schon kaufen
kann und bekannt wurde ist durch filme
wie star wars
grund genug für viele
science-fiction-fans die aktion zu
unterstützen insgesamt 451 unterstützer
gab es und 4 davon
die haben sogar 2100 und gespendet und
im ersten modell hatte das wieder bei
gries auch genannt wird nur zwei
propeller und im neuen in der neuen
version wird es vier propeller haben per
linienflug ins weltall
die hamburger firma wie plain möchte
linienflüge ins weltall ermöglichen rund
150000 euro soll ein flug inklusive fünf
minuten schwerelosigkeit kosten bislang
läuft dieser flug allerdings nur in
simulationen ab das projekt wird von
einem internationalen konsortium namens
booster von belgien aus geleitet
insgesamt sind mehr als 30 nationen
daran beteiligt der weltraumtourismus
ist aber nur ein kleiner teil des ganzen
die wissenschaft ist sehr interessiert
an den flügen denn so lassen sich
beispielsweise billiger und einfacher
versuche in der schwerelosigkeit
durchführen zunächst verkündete booster
gründer james mary dass die ersten
weltraumflüge bereits 2016 möglich sind
mittlerweile wurde diese angabe aber
nach hinten korrigiert die flügel sind
jetzt gegen ende dieses jahrzehnts
möglich frühestens das hamburger
unternehmen steht damit allerdings nicht
alleine war auch das us unternehmen
virgin galactic des multi milliardärs
richard branson plant linienflüge ins
weltall
seit 2009 wird die erste geplante
mission immer wieder aufgeschoben
diese ambitionen sollten den weg für
einen neuen markt ebnen durch einige
technische probleme muss das projekt
aber immer wieder verschoben werden
zum beispiel bereitet der antrieb der
flugzeuge derzeit probleme meint ulrich
walter ex astronaut um professor für
raumfahrttechnik an der technischen
universität münchen schon 600 personen
haben sich beim amerikanisch unternehmen
ein ticket für 250.000 dollar gekauft
jetzt steht das unternehmen unter druck
nach ihren angaben sind linienflüge ins
weltall erst nächstes jahr möglich
ebola verbreitungsweg simuliert die
globale ausbreitung des ebola erreger
kann mit einer computersimulation
berechnet werden der brockmann von der
berliner humboldt-universität und dirk
helbing von der eth zürich haben eine
interaktive grafik entwickelt die
anzeigt wie das ebola virus durch den
flugverkehr verbreitet werden kann
eine ebola pandemie gilt bislang zwar
als unwahrscheinlich dennoch
prognostiziert die
weltgesundheitsorganisation bis zu
20.000 infizierte in den nächsten
monaten in ihren berechnungen
berücksichtigen die forscher 1227
flughäfen
generell stehen hinter ihrer simulation
zwei wahrscheinlichkeiten einerseits die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein ebola
infizierte überhaupt in ein flugzeug
steigt und andererseits die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass er
beispielsweise nach europa führt diese
zwei zahlenwerte seien gering wenn man
sie kombiniert gehen sie sogar gegen
null aber eben nicht gleich null meinte
brockmann
in europa sei das mit abstand wichtigste
einfallstor der flughafen charles de
gaulle in paris
wenn man vom start der verbreitung in
conakry in guinea ausgeht
der ebola erreger treffe dieser fiktiven
annahme zufolge zuerst in mauretanien
gambia und dem senegal ein
deutschland ist aufgrund der wenigen
direktverbindung weniger gefährdet
aufgrund mangelnder daten lassen sich
mit der simulation keine rückschlüsse
auf die tatsächlichen infizierten zahlen
ziehen wir wissen zwar wie viele
menschen täglich guinea über kontakte
per flugzeug verlassen meint der
physiker wir können derzeit aber noch
nicht berechnen nach wie vielen tagen
wir mit ebola infizierten europa rechnen
müssen da das vom weiteren verlauf der
epidemie in westafrika abhängt mit dem
modell lässt sich auch feststellen was
die schließung von flugverbindungen für
auswirkungen auf die verbreitung des
ebola-virus hat bislang
stehe aber das problem dass jede airline
anders mit der problematik umgehe
so hat zb british airways die flügel
nach guinea liberia und sierra leone
schon anfang august gestrichen
air france dagegen hat seinen flugplan
erst auf drängen der französischen
regierung vor etwa einer woche geändert
sap map halt infizierte ab und noch eine
meldung zum thema ebola rhesusaffen die
mit teils starken ebner symptomen zu
kämpfen hatten konnten geheilt werden
die heilung gelang auch wenn den affen
das medikament selbst bis zu fünf tage
nach einer infektion mit dem ebola
erreger verabreicht wurde das fanden
jetzt kanadische forscher in einer
studie heraus ob das medikament auch
beim menschen so gut wirkt ist bislang
allerdings nicht erwiesen
insgesamt wurde der wirkstoff 18 nach
von verabreicht bei sechs von ihnen lag
die infektion mit dem hi virus bereits
einige tage zurück die affen wiesen
teilweise schon symptome wie fieber eine
erhöhte zahl weißer blutkörperchen und
einen mangel an blutplättchen auf sogar
schleim aus blutungen konnten geheilt
werden
die drei kontrolltiere der studie
starben allerdings in der studie wurden
eine andere variante des ebola weniger
benutzt in versuchen eine zellkultur mit
dem derzeit in westafrika umgehenden
virustyp konzept mit jedoch die
vermehrung des erregers unterbinden
das serum und die erfolgreiche
behandlung der affen seien ein
imposanter erfolg beschreibt der
immunologe thomas wey gaisberg von der
university of texas in austin
die monatelangen entwicklungen am
menschen ist das medikament allerdings
noch nicht sehr erprobt in seinem
kommentar verweist auf die patientin
rudi ist die mit dem serum erfolgreich
behandelt wurden zwei ebola infizierte
seien trotz therapie gestorben bei ihnen
kam den workshop vermutlich zu spät
die heilung der patienten sei aber kein
beleg für die wirkung wäre etwa die
hälfte der ebola kranken ohne therapie
sowieso überlebt hätte
weiter geht's mit einem ausführlichen
bericht zum thema raumfahrt für alle wie
es für immer mehr menschen möglich wird
in den weltraum zu reisen und täglich
wissenschaften uns gibt's im blog oder
in der app dafür ihr kriegt was man ihr
gibt es bald ein massentaugliches
medikament gegen die ebola apple
wie wollt ihr einen linienflug ins
weltall mitmachen diskutiert ist wie
immer mit mir in den kommentaren
allerdings wie immer in der video
beschreibung und bis dann bleibt dran